this oops I scrolled too far all right
there was the first trick example now
this next truth example it feels like it
goes right off the deep end but I
promise it's going to really use the
same principle that we looked at before
let's step through this one at a time it
says show that this derivative the
derivative of this I should say will
give you sine cubed x and hence find
this thing this integral okay now why is
the question phrased in this way the
whole point here is that you will
encounter functions that you don't know
how to integrate off the face of it you
know it's not something it's not some
standard form that you've memorized with
some rule that you're like ah so n cubed
x always turns into this okay so
therefore they help you out in
integrating this what they do is they
say if you work out this guy over here
that will help you so let's try that out
and then see how we can use that
knowledge to finish out the whole
question how do I do this well let's
let's start by differentiating when they
tell you to prove that something equals
something else if they want you to prove
that say for example this is grants
let's go they want you to prove that a
equals B don't start off by saying a
equals B and then do some stuff and then
sure those things end up being you know
equal like one equals one or something
like that that's not a way to prove
something because you have started off
assuming that the statements true you've
written a equals B right so of course
it's going to work out okay
I can actually make things that are
incorrect like two equals one I just
multiplied both sides by zero and then
you get a right statement at the end
that doesn't print the two equals one
that's rubbish okay so instead what you
need to do not that instead what you
need to do is start with one side like a
the left hand side and then start doing
some things on it and then hopefully
after doing enough things you'll end at
B well you could do it in the reverse
order if you prefer and it was more
convenient to you in this case I'm gonna
start on the left because I've got a
theme to differentiate I know how to
differentiate let's go for it okay the
thing I'm differentiating is slightly
monstrous it's a third cause cubed X and
I'm going to take this opportunity to
write that as cos x cubed minus cos x
hmm I died deal with this all right well
firstly let's look
take each term in turn so there's a
first term in here and then there's a
second one let's choose a more
contrasting color in here so we'll deal
with the red part first okay for
starters there's just a third is a
constant coefficient hanging out the
front there so I'm just gonna leave that
there and then what I get is this cause
X cubed so this is the function of a
function I need to use the chain rule
here right so I'm going to do the I'll
do the inside then I'll do the outside
the inside function is cos X what is the
derivative of cos X its negative sine X
there's the inside done I've got the
outside which is cos x or cubed so when
something's cubes and I'm doing that I'm
gonna bring the index out the front and
then I'm gonna divide by that new index
so I'm gonna get 3 cos x squared okay so
now I've done the inside I've done the
outside the red thing is done let's have
a look at the the blue one I've got a
minus sign that was just carried over
from the original expression and then
cos x what's the derivative of cos x we
just did it didn't we it's negative sine
X I'm gonna put in negative sine X okay
at this point I need to do a bunch of
simplification so let's see what we can
tidy up here
maybe I'll keep my red in my blue just
for now I can see there's going to be
this 1/3 and this 3 they're gonna cancel
with each other so just get one and then
lastly I had this minus sign right so
that is the only thing that gets left at
the front a minus sign through the a
minus 1 right then I've got sine X and
then cos X all squared as we saw before
a shorthand way of writing that is cos
squared X so there you go there's the
there's the red derivative now this blue
derivative wrong color I've got two
negatives so it just ends up being
cancelled out and you get plus sine X
okay now at this point a lot of you will
look at this and scratch your head
you'll be like whoo well know what like
I mean I've done the differentiation
I've tidied it up it looks simpler than
what I started with that's true
but I haven't proven what I
is asked to do at the beginning right
you can see this is where I was ended
meant to end up right this was meant to
be my be my end point okay so whenever
you're proving things like this you keep
one eye on the working and a second eye
on your destination so you know which
way to head when I realize I'm heading
to something like sine cubed X the thing
that stands out to me is there are no
cosine terms in here right there are no
causes it's just sines so what that says
to me is this cause in here like I've
got to get rid of it somehow right it
shouldn't it doesn't belong it shouldn't
be there okay so I'll color in different
things so you don't confuse it with the
green in the previous line how do I get
rid of cosines and replace them with
signs well there's a bunch of ways to do
this but if you think back the most
helpful way is something we learned last
year called the Pythagorean identity
this comes from using trigonometry in
the unit circle and using Pythagoras its
Pythagorean theorem identity I should
say this is what the Pythagorean
identity tells us sine squared plus
collar squared equals 1 so how do I use
this to get rid of cos Squared's and
replace them with signs well what I'm
going to do here is I'm going to
rearrange this equation here in orange
and I'm going to make cos squared the
subject to do that I am going to
subtract sine squared from both sides so
I get 1 minus sine squared on the right
hand side okay now I hope you can see
you can take this term here on the left
and notice that it's the same as the cos
squared X in my actual line so I can
substitute in the right hand side since
these two things are equivalent right so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna write the
minus out the front sine X and I'm going
to write 1 minus sine squared as my
substitution so here is the use of the
Pythagorean identity now it looks like
things are getting Messier
not simpler but you have to have a
little faith right once I take this guy
and I actually expand these brackets
you're gonna see everything come out in
the wash I've got a minus sine X excuse
me at the front and then I've got a
watch
carefully let's choose this I've got a
minus sign X multiplied by a minus sign
squared X so number one the negatives
cancel leaving me with a plus and then
the sine x times sine squared X is sine
cubed X which is exactly what we are
hoping for when you have that plus sine
X along the end you can see that these
two guys here and here are going to
cancel which leaves us with the sine
cubed X that we were looking for so I'm
gonna conclude by saying sine cubed X as
required all right now what have we done
what have we established well we have
shown like the question asked that that
derivative on the left hand side leaves
you with sine cubed X how does this help
us well the question itself asks us to
find the integral of sine cubed x from
naught to PI on three so this sine cubed
X is the thing I have on the right hand
side all I need to do to find out the
answer to this is to integrate with
respect to X from naught to PI on three
so I'm gonna take this right hand side
and I'm going to integrate it from
naught to PI on three with respect to X
now over and over again we've been
seeing if you do something to one side
of the equation you've got to do it to
the other so I'm going to get the
integral not just at the right hand side
by the integral the left now if you
differentiate something and then you
integrate it then you're just going to
end up back where you started
plus a constant if you have an
indefinite integral but I don't have an
indefinite integral I have a definite
integral right so therefore when I
integrate this I'm going to end up
exactly where I started cos x or cubed
minus cos x so long as I am actually
doing a definite integral from naught to
PI on three you can see I've just taken
the same boundaries from the right hand
side and I've got them there on the left
hand side so that's the hardest part of
this now I'm ready to actually just
evaluate the thing let me move this guy
over to the left because that's where we
normally put the subject of the equation
and move it down a little bit just so I
got a little more space and now let's
just complete the substitution by
evaluating each of the boundaries we've
got a big set of brackets here what have
I got here so 1/3 of cos PI on 3 which
is cubed minus cos of Pi on 3
there's the upper boundary and then I'm
gonna subtract the lower boundary so
it's 1/3 of cos 0 cubed minus cos 0 all
right I'm gonna need my exact values
here again so what do I got I got 1/3
times this is cos of Pi on 3 so in
degrees this is cos of 60 degrees that's
1/2 but remember the half has been cubed
see that you've got 1/2 times 1/2 times
1/2 so that's gonna be 1 over 8 and then
I'm going to subtract just 1/2 because
that's cos PI on 3 there's the upper
boundary let's do it for the bottom
boundary
I've got 1/3 times cos 0 cube now cos 0
we saw before is just 1 so 1 cubed is
also 1 so I'm just gonna subtract okay
I'm getting there what have I got now
I've got 1 over 24 since that's in 24 so
I might as well put this in 24th so
there's 12 of those and then I've got
let's see here in the end 1/3 take away
1 is negative 2/3 but I might as well
write that in 24 2/3 will be negative 16
over 24 just to a mentor check on there
yet divide the top and bottom by 8
you'll get negative 2/3 all right
everything's in 24 so let's start
simplifying yeah I've got negative 11
twenty fourth stair double negative
cancels plus 16 so I'm getting my looks
of things 5 over 24 so it seems like a
lot of work to get such a simple answer
but that's one of the geniuses of all of
the knowledge that we've developed in
calculus so far and in trigonometry you
can see I had to use some trigonometric
identities that maybe a not familiar
with you with you for a while I had to
simplify a lot of algebra here and then
I had to use some exact values like we
saw earlier